jetzt geht es ja weiterhin im deutschen
parlament mit einem antrag der afg sie
will darin die distanzierung der
bundesregierung von dennis von
äußerungen von deniz yücel denis hughes
ist ja seit 2005 10 korrespondent der
welt und war am vergangenen freitag nach
über einem jahr aus türkischer haft
entlassen worden und dennis mitchell hat
davor für die tageszeitung taz für die
taz gearbeitet und in ihrem antrag nennt
die fdp-fraktion you shall einen
ausgewiesenen deutschland und deutschen
hasser und wirft ihm volksverhetzende
äußerungen vor die stehe missverhältnis
zur vorzugsbehandlung des journalisten
durch die bundesregierung der afg antrag
bezieht sich auf satirische und
besonders bissige texte in der
tageszeitung taz modell wie gesagt bis
2015 arbeitete dort hatte er sich in
einer kolumne im jahr 2011 satirisch mit
dem bevölkerungsrückgang in deutschland
befasst die politiker hatten den text in
dem auch die formulierung der baldigen
abgang der deutschen aber ist völker
sterben von seiner schönsten seite stand
wiederholt kritisiert mitchell hatte
außerdem den buchautor thilo sarrazin
einen weiteren schlaganfall gewünscht
was der taz eine unterlassungsklage und
eine rüge des presserates einbrachte
jetzt veröffentlichte daraufhin eine
klarstellung und dieses hier dient also
heute nun der diskussion dass die
bundesregierung sich von diesen eine
veröffentlichung distanzieren solle die
afg verlangt das sind der namentlich
über diesen antrag abgestimmt wird
deswegen ist das parlament zu dieser
späten stunde hier auch noch erfreulich
gut gefüllt und die abgeordnete wir in
den ungefähr 45 minuten ohnehin hier
aufgerufen werden ihr stimmt kärtchen
einzuwerfen es hat im vorfeld darüber
schon viel aufregung gegeben der
deutsche journalisten verband warf der
fdp fraktion vor das parlament für
menschen hetze zu missbrauchen
es sei geradezu absurd dass die afg im
bundestag als bühne für ihr gestörtes
verhältnis zur presse und
meinungsfreiheit benutzen will
kritisierte der djv bundesvorsitzende
frank überall und der erste redner kommt
natürlich von der afg er ist der obmann
im innenausschuss gottfried curio wird
es sein und er wird hier gleich den
antrag der fdp-fraktion im einzelnen
begründen
dann bist so beschlossen
ich rufe auf den soeben aufgesetzten
zusatzpunkt 7 eine aussprache ist nicht
vorgesehen
beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für wahlprüfung immunität
und geschäftsordnung auf drucksache 881
zu dem antrag auf genehmigung zur
durchführung eines strafverfahrens
der ausschuss empfiehlt die genehmigung
zu erteilen bestimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung danke bestimmt
dagegen dank averatec sich die
beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig an
sobald dann ich werde ihnen das nach
liefern müssen im moment bin ich aber
linken fuß erwischt peter bauer hat ja
hier abstimmen lassen
über die aufhebung der immunität eines
abgeordneten ich kann ihnen nicht genau
sagen um welche abgeordneten es sich
gehandelt hat den antrag werden
nach einer interfraktionellen
vereinbarung sind für die aussprache 38
minuten vorgesehen
ich höre dazu kein widerspruch dann ist
so geschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
der abgeordnete dr godfrey curio für die
fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
seeger präsident geehrte abgeordnete die
afg begrüßt die freilassung von herrn
yücel aus politischer willkür haft
begrüßt den erfolg der außerordentlichen
bemühungen der bundesregierung
wir bedauern aber ebenso dass eine
freilassung weiterer zu unrecht
inhaftierte nicht mit gleicher
intensität betrieben wurde und aus steht
die politische bevorzugung von yücel
wurde nicht begründet wirft aber die
frage auf ob hier ohne ansehen der
person gehandelt wurde
zu vermeiden ist der mögliche eindruck
dass mit seiner ganz außerordentlichen
vorzugsbehandlung eine stille billigung
seiner wohlbekannten deutschland
feindlichen äußerungen einhergeht
geboten erscheint deshalb dass die
bundesregierung eine missbilligung
dieser äußerung ausspricht
selbstverständlich selbstverständlich
soll die freiheit sich so zu äußern
erhalten bleiben selbstverständlich soll
dagegen jetzt nicht rechtlich
vorgegangen werden natürlich soll die
bundesregierung sich nicht zu jeder
schmierung äußern aber wenn diese eine
person so herausgehoben wird so muss die
ganze geschichte erzählt werden
das hohe lied das auf herrn niessl
angestimmt wird kann den missklang
seiner äußerungen nicht übertönen
steigen wir also in den morast des
tatsächlichen dem autor
dem autor der den niedergang
deutschlands beklagt thilo sarrazin ihm
wünscht der user den tod
zitat möge der nächste schlaganfall sein
werk gründlicher verrichten an dieser
menschen karikatur gemeinde sarrazin
das ist unser geliebter dennis überhaupt
diese uns aufgedrängte vornamen
vertraulichkeit wir deutschen und unser
dennis wann sind wir nur zu dieser
herzliche verbundenheit gekommen
diese ikone der links presse also mit
ihrer menschenverachtenden sarrazin
äußerung so jemand ist für frau merkel
ein fall besonderer dringlichkeit für
user ist der baldiger abgang der
deutschen völker sterben von seiner
schönsten seite
das ist für herrn gabriel ein deutscher
patriot user freut sich aufs deutschen
sterben für ihn betont gabriel habe er
sich zweimal mit präsident erdogan
getroffen user meint etwas besseres als
deutschland findet sich allemal
gabriel chefkoch im braten von extra
würsten betont er habe mehrfach mit dem
türkischen außenminister cavusoglu
gesprochen
huzel will dass deutschland zwischen
frankreich und polen aufgeteilt oder in
einem rübenacker verwandelt wird das ist
für gabriel ein brückenbauer vielleicht
zwischen frankreich und polen insel
freut sich dass das unvollendete werk
das das unvollendete werk von bomber
harris und ilja ehrenburg massentötung
und massenvergewaltigung endlich
vollendet wird heiko maas ausgerechnet
der erfinder des tatbestands hast
wittert bei freilassung beste nachricht
wo gibt ähnlich besoffen vorfreude gibt
sich ein ganzer reigen von politikern an
medienleuten bestimmter couleur während
dieser hassprediger gegen alle deutschen
hetzt schwelgend in gruppenbezogener
menschenfeindlichkeit wahrlich rassismus
pur
und dann soll mit dem verweis auf
angebliche satire die alles dürfe
übertreibung ist da aber nur eine
tarnkappe für wirklichen hast dann soll
ein zwei klassen redefreiheit eingeführt
werden eine für establishment nahe
antideutsche und eine für patriotische
normal deutsche äußert der antideutsche
linke ist es satire äußert der
normalbürger kritik an der regierung ist
es hans maaß bestimmt wassertiere ist
gabriel wie ein patriot ist willkommen
in der welt der 16 prozent partei
übrigens gibt es für herrn hughes allen
hoffnung wenn er den abgang der
deutschen beschleunigt sehen will so
kann er als doppelstarter hierzu rein
numerisch effektiv beitragen indem er
die ihm offenbar verhasste deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft abgibt das wäre doch
ehrlich und überfällig
und sonst die presse lässt die regierung
gut aussehen frau merkel hält ihre
geheimen pressetreffen ab und sagt was
dran ist man sorgt für einander
wir wissen nicht wie viel munition und
panzer material für diese top geisel
gedealt werden wird wie viele kurden
werden sterben müssen aber jedenfalls
können politiker und presse diese höchst
wundersame freilassung ihrer ikone
bejubeln die bevölkerung aber muss man
vermuten dass die große politik sondern
klimmzüge für gesinnungsfreunde macht
und durch antideutsche hetze nicht etwa
abgeschreckt sondern zu diplomatischen
höchstleistungen angespornt wird hier
würde eine missbilligung klarheit
schaffen
und wenn man herrn user jetzt schaut wie
er gabriels gedenkt so ahnt man dass er
als letztes wort wollen wir es uns
denken mit blick auf letzte umfragen
sagen würde denn es der alte satiriker
der baldiger abgang aber der spd ist
parteien sterben von seiner schönsten
seite
ich dagegen zu meine damen und herren
ich war noch die nachtrags schuldig ist
handelte sich um frauke petry deren
immunität hier eben aufgehoben worden
ist die dresdner staatsanwaltschaft
klagt sie wegen mutmaßlicher sicher
falschaussage vor dem sächsischen
landtag anders war ich ihnen noch
schuldig und sie haben ja jetzt hier die
begründung für den antrag der afw gehört
wird curio hat diese szene eingebracht
angekommen muss ich bitte also alle ihre
plätze einzunehmen und damit die nötige
aufmerksamkeit herzustellen für die
erste rede im deutschen bundestag des
kollegen alexander throm aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion und alexander throm ist
im innenausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen nach dem er so
viel gift verspritzt wurde will ich
zunächst damit beginnen dass es für uns
für die cdu/csu-fraktion zuallererst ein
grund zur freude und dankbarkeit ist
dass er michelle der über ein jahr aus
rein politischen gründen inhaftiert war
endlich frei gekommen ist
und da die überschrift ihres antrags
verhalten der bundesregierung im fall
michelle lautet gib mir dass die
gelegenheit eben dieses verhalten zu
loben
es war vorbildlich eine klare
hartnäckige und unnachgiebige haltung
auf allen ebenen gegenüber der türkei
hat sich durchgesetzt
unser dank gilt allen in der
bundesregierung die daran beteiligt
waren
zuallererst der bundeskanzlerin und dem
vizekanzler
der dank geht aber auch an alle anderen
in der zivilgesellschaft an die
journalistischen kollegen an die anwälte
an alle die dazu beigetragen haben dass
der druck auf die türkische regierung so
groß wurde dass sie letztlich nachgeben
musste und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dieser fall michelle und der
umgang mit ihm ist geradezu ein
paradebeispiel für unseren freiheitlich
dem von unserem freiheitlich
demokratischen rechtsstaat für unsere
haltung zur meinungs- und pressefreiheit
auf der einen und den schutz unserer
staatsbürger auf der anderen seite wir
lassen es nicht zu dass jemand in seiner
meinungs- und pressefreiheit
eingeschränkt wird und zwar unabhängig
davon ob wir diesen auffassung teilen
oder nicht und schon gar nicht
akzeptieren wir das als journalist wegen
seiner politischen meinungsäußerung ohne
anklage ohne rechtsstaatliches verfahren
inhaftiert wird die freiheit und
unabhängigkeit der presse ist ein hohes
gut das wir schützen und dafür gibt es
auch keine vorzugsbehandlung wie dies
behauptet wird während die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit hat erhält den
schutz des deutschen staates
uneingeschränkt das galt für mediale
tono und kälter steudtner und
selbstverständlich für herrn mitchell
und das gilt auch für die anderen
weiterhin inhaftierten deutschen in
türkischen gefängnissen und ja der grat
zwischen freier meinungsäußerung und der
verletzung der persönlichkeit eines
anderen ist schmal
es muss niemandem gefallen was den xl
2011 2012 in seinen als satire erkennbar
und texten über herr sarrazin und zuvor
zu dessen buch geschrieben hat man muss
es wirklich nicht gut finden
doch dafür gab es teilweise sanktionen
vom presserat und die gerichtliche
untersagung der weiteren verbreitung
die afg will heute eine missbilligung
aussprechen
doch der bundestag ist der falsche ort
für eine bewertung einer satire
wir sind hier kein literarisches
quartett
und dieser schmale grat gilt auch für
die afg auch für frau weit ich bedauere
dass sie heute nicht der debatte sei
wollte sie hat er das letzte wochenende
fast gar nichts getan als über twitter
und andere medien zu dem fall michelle
sich zu äußern
da hat sie in einer twitter meldung am
tag nach einer entlassung ihn als
antideutschen hassprediger beschimpft da
hat sie auch dieser grad überschritten
herr hickel hatte immerhin die größe
sich nach seinem kritikwürdigen text zu
entschuldigen
ich wage zu bezweifeln dass diese größe
ebenfalls
und sie hat in dieser twitter-meldung
ich zitiere geschrieben dass einer der
nicht nur einmal die grenzen des guten
geschmacks verließ eigentlich keine
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft besitzen
sollte doch die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft ist keine frage des
guten geschmacks die afg wie sich hier
als patrioten darstellen so eine aussage
ist aber alles andere als patriotisch
sie schlicht und einfach erbärmlich
und nun zu ihren kollegen gucken
er hat am aschermittwoch die türken in
deutschland aus übelste beleidigt und
damit ganz sicher die grenzen des guten
geschmacks verlassen
darüber sind wir uns doch glatt
deutschland einig sie haben ihn ja
schließlich abgemahnt ich habe dann aber
jetzt noch mal warten sie doch mal ab
jetzt warten sie doch ab
ich habe dann das genau dasselbe getan
wie die frau weise zu herrn rietschel
ich habe lange gesucht hat doch der dow
land legen adopter gaul und regen sich
doch nicht so auf ich habe lange gesucht
bei twitter bei facebook irgendein zitat
in welt üblich finden konnte dass sie
ebenfalls ab offenburg seine deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft absprechen wollte
nichts dergleichen von day findet
und dort ein letztes zum thema guter
geschmack guten geschmack kann man nicht
immer in gesetze und normen fassen geht
manchmal ganz banal um anstand
menschlichkeit und mitgefühl und da
kommt ein mensch der über einem jahr
haft frei größtenteils in isolationshaft
verbracht aus einem land in dem
rechtsstaatliche grundsätze nicht in dem
maße gelten wie wir sie kennen und
erwarten und ihre frau weigel hat nichts
anderes zu tun aus als aus ihrem warmen
und sicheren abgeordnetenbüro heraus
diesen menschen per twitter zu
beschimpfen zu diskreditieren und dann
einen derartigen antrag zu stellen wie
sie es heute tun das ist kollektive
unanständigkeit deshalb
und da
und deshalb weil das verhalten der
bundesregierung das ist der titel der
debatte vorbildlich war ihre kritik ist
genau das gegenteil darf und deshalb
wegen wir den antrag ab applaus aus
allen fraktionen außer der afg für die
jungfernrede von alexander throm im
innenausschuss ist ja der jurist aus
heilbronn der hier für seine rede
mächtig applaus erhält hat gesagt hat
der bundestag ist doch kein
literarisches quartett
nächster redner jetzt so lars
castellucci von der spd auch erst
mitglied im innenausschuss präsidentin
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
antrag der afd enthält tatsächlich einen
vernünftigen satz das ist schon mehr als
ich erwartet habe
und das ist gleich der erste der
deutsche bundestag begrüßt die
freilassung und dennis michelle aus
politischer willkür haft in der tat das
begrüßen wir hier alle
und jetzt auch nicht vom himmel gefallen
deswegen auch von meiner seite und von
der seite meiner fraktion herzlichen
dank allen die sich dafür eingesetzt
haben die öffentlichkeit erzeugt haben
sofort das unseren geschäftsführenden
bundesaußenminister sigmar gabriel der
bundeskanzlerin allen die mitgeholfen
haben ein herzlicher dank für dieses
engagement
schön dass es von erfolg gekrönt und wie
man an dieser stelle sieht der deutsche
staat schützt seine bürgerinnen und
bürger im inneren und sogar wenn sie
irgendwo auf der welt in gefängnissen
landen und ich finde das eigentlich ein
zeitpunkt wo wir stolz auf unser land
sein könnten und diesen stolz ausdruck
verleihen dem sie ja so gerne ausdruck
verleihen den stolz das wäre einmal eine
gelegenheit gewesen
auch für die kollegen kollege von der a
steht der erste satz den sie hier
geschrieben haben den wollten sie
eigentlich weiter schreiben der stadt
steht der deutsche bundestag begrüßt die
freilassung von dennis michelle aus
politischer willkür haft in die er von
ihrem bruder im geiste tayyip erdogan
hineingeworfen
denn der erdogan hat es nicht so mit der
meinungsfreiheit und der pressefreiheit
und sie haben es auch nicht so mit der
pressefreiheit und der meinungsfreiheit
und wissen sie was
der sechste teil schade für die auf das
sie sitzen hier im deutschen parlament
und ich fordere sie auf dass die politik
auf der grundlage unseres grundgesetzes
machen und dass sie diesen antrag
zurückziehen
sie können uns hier nicht auffordern zu
missbilligen irgendwelche äußerungen die
journalistisch fallen dann dann dieser
sache mit dieser vorzugsbehandlung geist
einer bevorzugt worden
während andere vergleichbare schicksale
weiterhin in den kerkern sitzen
weiterhin unschuldig eingesperrt sind ja
doch ich gedacht oh ha die ard jetzt
wird sie uns mal aufschreiben was man
machen könnte
für diese ganzen anderen leute die
unschuldig irgendwo eingekerkert sehen
die unschuldig in den gefängnissen die
unschuldig in den gefängnissen sitzen
und dann pausieren kommt natürlich
überhaupt nichts sondern sie verwenden
diese vergleichbaren schicksale nur um
auf den eigenen anderen zu zeigen und
dann vorzuwerfen
ausgerechnet dem helft ihr so wissen sie
an was mich das erinnert sie sind doch
das christliche abendland
es gebe ich ihnen mal christliches
abendland wenn sie die geschichte wo
dieses altöl dass teures öl vergossen
wurde und judas dann kam judas der
später zum verräter wurde und sagte nein
dieses teure salz öl das sollten wir
nicht aus gießen das soll wir verkaufen
damit wir es den armen geben können das
geld und dann steht da als nächster satz
geschrieben aber judas ging es gar nicht
um die armen denn er war ein dieb und
das finde ich sehr vergleichbar mit der
situation so wie sie von dem rentner
reden der ein leben lang gearbeitet hat
und der mit einer kleinen rente da steht
aber ich habe von ihnen noch nie auf
ihrer eigenen vorschlag zur verbesserung
von renten in diesem parlament
der sänger wird nur auch ausländer sowie
die wurst das ist doch verwerflich und
des wertes mit chile und starten sie
eine frage oder bewertung
ich werde mit ihnen streiten und
diskutieren wenn ihr mal über sachfragen
reden aber nicht solange sie uns solche
peinlichen anträge hier vorlegen über
diese zeit verlieren vergeudete
lebenszeit und jetzt herr kurioser denn
sie sind doch ein studierter man sie
können mir doch nicht erzählen dass sie
nicht in der lage sind zwischen einer
satire aus der sich ständig zitieren und
einem normalen text hier zu
unterscheiden
das können sie mir doch nicht erzählen
da machen sie uns noch was vor wissen
sie was wissen sie was ich helfe ihnen
mal dabei
wir lernen hier mal ein bisschen satire
wissen sie was deniz yücel zu ihrem
antrag sagen würde achtung satire der
würde sagen da steht 'beste antrag wo
gibt von ganze welt
lars castellucci war das von der spd
auch er hielt phasenweise sie aus allen
fraktionen außer der alten fraktion
applaus für seinen wortbeitrag wolfgang
kubicki jetzt für die fdp frau
präsidentin liebe kollegen zunächst
einmal möchte ich mich bei meiner
fraktion bedanken dass sie mir die
gelegenheit gibt frei von präsidiale
zurückhaltung in die politische debatte
einzugreifen und das auch noch zu einem
paar de antrag aber ich bin höchst mit
euch
weil das nicht um einen antrag von
intellektuelle erbärmlichkeit handelt
wir lesen dass die bundesregierung den
fall gesondert behandelt haben soll
ja ich komme gleich darauf zurück herr
brandner und das sei empörend
aber statt die bundesregierung dafür zu
rügen
das wäre eine maßnahme legten sie sofort
auch den betroffenen davon und erklären
eigentlich er sei es nicht wert dass man
sich um ihn gekümmert hat und sie
belegen dass und sie belegen dass sie
belegen dass mit zitaten aus kolumbien
des jahres 2011 und 2012 das alleine
schon ist erbärmlich weil wir erwarten
könnten dass sie mit das mit 90 tagen
machen würden
ja er dran das ist ja ihre meinung ich
komme gerne darauf zurück die welt hat
heute dankenswerter weise dokumentiert
und zwar ein unnachahmlicher art dass
sie behaupten der sonder behandlung
falsch ist und das kann auch
nachvollziehen und ich sage ihnen mal
ich sehe ihnen nach der tiere nicht
verstehen und deshalb solche anträge
stellen aber was ich aber was ich ihnen
nicht mehr sicher brander ich habe ja
gehört ein studierter jurist nicht nach
zunächst dass sie die bundesregierung
auffordern wollen was rechts - was
verfassungswidriges zu tun
sie fordern die bundesregierung auf
einen journalisten wegen seiner
äußerungen zu missbilligen und sie
wissen aus eigener sie wissen aus
eigener geschichte ja auch der serie
organstreitverfahren in sachen banker
das verfassungsgericht festgestellt hat
dass bundesregierung dazu gar nicht
befugt ist weil ich der eindruck
entstehen darf das hier direkt oder
indirekt zensur ausgeübt wird
sie haben sich was sie angeht beschwert
oder maßnahme bundesregierung
und jetzt kommen sie und vor allem
bestellungen aufgenommen gast zu tun
worüber sie sich beschwert haben das
nenne ich intellektuell ziemlich
erbärmlich kollegen publikum
besonders besonders gerne weil diese
zeit verlängert starten sie eine frage
möchtest fortbildung beitrag geehrter
herr kollege kubicki die sonne der
behandlung des herrn betzel ist die eine
sache aber etwas ganz anderes ist doch
der umstand dass in diesem hohen hause
es scheinbar nicht mehr möglich ist
äußerungen die direkt oder indirekt den
volkstod unseres volkes verlangen
zufügen und herr kubicki sind sie nicht
vielleicht mit mir gemeinsam der meinung
dass das für dieses hohe haus ein
wirklich erbärmliches schauspiel es also
zunächst einmal müssten mittel stehen
bleiben wenn sie eine antwort bekommen
zumal herr kollege
[Musik]
zunächst einmal hat obwohl sein darf ich
antworten zunächst zunächst einmal herr
kollege
er hat sich niemand daran gehindert hier
ihre reden zu halten und zu rügen was
sich beruhigungs fähigkeiten das muss
man im rahmen der meinungsfreiheit auch
vertragen geschafft diese so aus aber
sie haben keinen anspruch sei aber auch
dass irgendein anderer abgeordneter
ihrer auffassung folgt das sieht die
verfassung nicht vor
und das werden wir auch nicht geben
und das war die antwort sie können sich
jetzt gerne wieder setzen auf dem land
ist es relativ egal ob sie stehen oder
sitzen aber die tatsache dass der
schutzschild im hinblick auf herrn
sarrazin sich daneben benommen hat ist
gerichtsfest festgestellt worden und wir
alle haben ja mal schlechte tage die auf
die mehr als andere aber jedenfalls
jedenfalls ist die
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzung nicht
wegzudiskutieren
und dafür muss man sich auch
verantworten dafür durch die taz
dankenswerterweise auf 20.000 euro
schadenersatz leisten anhören das mag
sein der kollege schon jetzt komme ich
zu ihnen persönlichkeit
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen sind
bei ihnen übrigens auch standard bei
ihnen persönlich möglicherweise nicht
kommen da drauf so bei ihnen aber es die
insgesamt ist das standard als der
kollege curio hier zum doppelpass
erklärt hat dass die
integrationsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung ein lebendes beispiel
dafür sei dass die doppelstadt dass die
integration gescheitert sei nämlich
nämlich nämlich das noch hin dass es für
mich grenzt her die ich vielleicht auch
unhöflich und anständig aber hinnehmbar
banane
aber das hat deutschland außerhalb
dieses hauses erklärt diese frau müsse
man entsorgen
es gilt frau müsse man entsorgen mit der
gleichen satire dürftiges auf 20.000
euro tisch legen der schüßler optisch
legen doch durch das klingt als wären
wir durch
aber das ist genauso sieht
möglichkeit rechtsverletzungen die wir
hier nicht der fall entsorgen spricht
und sie wird dabei immer dass es darum
geht lässt oder abfall zu entsorgen und
ein mensch ist kein abfall gauland der
dollar die taz hat sich die taz die tat
sich bei herrn sarrazin gibt hat sich
bei den soldaten entschuldigt
was ist global das ist anständig dass
sie dass sie sich bei der
integrationsbeauftragten der muss dafür
nicht entschuldigen
zeitlich unanständig sie einen dies sind
und das ist keine politik hier in
deutschland wollen ich bin in diesem
land ich bin in diesem land geboren
ich bin hier aufgewachsen hier war eine
möglichkeit habe ich bin stolz auf
dieses land
ich möchte nicht eine situation wo mich
dauernd dafür schämen muss das
politische entscheidungsträger in diesem
land wieder so reden wie sie herzlichen
dank wolfgang kubicki der
bundestags-vizepräsident und
rechtsanwalt hat auch ihre viel applaus
von allen fraktionen es ist mal wieder
eine veranstaltung alle gegen die afg
oder umgekehrt die achte hingegen alle
auch begründet dadurch dass die afg hier
einen antrag vorgelegt hat der wirklich
vielleicht gar nicht in dieses haus
gebracht werden sollte jan korte jetzt
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
ihn wichtige dinge die wir hier
diskutieren müssten armutsrenten
kinderarmut kriege und vieles andere
mehr
was ist der afg wichtig in dieser woche
ist hier folgendes wichtig sie hat eine
aktuelle stunde beantragt zu ihrer
eigenen demo die irgendwie nicht
geklappt hat und heute möchte sie dass
der bundestag äußerung eines
journalisten unter anderem missbilligt
der ware titel für ihren antrag müsste
eigentlich lauten wenn er denn sachlich
begründbar wäre voll crash der afg mit
der pressefreiheit und den grundrechten
das ist der kern ihres
und ich will auch etwas anderes ich will
auch etwas anderes kommen alle haben wir
das gesehen in diesem land dieses bild
von dennis michelle wie er seine frau
nach einem jahr unschuldig im knast
sitzen in den arm genommen hat und es
ist ja eigentlich so dass menschen einen
inneren kompass haben mit mitgefühl mit
menschlichkeit mit freude wenn sich
menschen sie dafür fallen wenn jemand
unschuldig im knast gesessen
dieser kompass ist bei ihnen vollständig
im eimer so viel niederschlag muss man
erst mal 70 zuhörer nur zu ihrer
fraktionsvorsitzenden sie hat gesagt die
shell ist wieder journalist noch
deutscher fällt ihnen was auffällt ihnen
was aus das ist der klassiker gerade
sich zu früh zu freuen
fällt ihnen eigentlich was auf ihre
kritik an deniz yücel gleicht exakt der
kritik des türkischen präsidenten
erdogan
sie sind der verlängerte arm von erdogan
und kanzlerin
schild und die pressefreiheit drauf
rosig aus denn auch denn auch der
türkische präsident fritz schellack
journalist zu sein dann sagt ihre
fraktionsvorsitzende weiter
ich zitiere ein journalist wie michelle
der nicht nur einmal die grenzen des
guten geschmackes verließ sollte
eigentlich keine deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft besitzt so ihre
fraktionsvorsitzende
zum einen kennen sie sich mit dem
verlassen des guten geschmackes liegt
kein anderer aus das ist wahr
aber und das ist ja der ernste teile
dahinter steckt natürlich ein motto und
das motto ist ich entscheide wer
deutscher ist und wer nicht und auch
dass es exakt dieselbe denke des
türkischen präsidenten ernannt der das
blut deutsche abgeordnete untersuchen
wollte
das ist beides völkisches denken was
dieses land und europa in den abgrund
geführt hat
hier nämlich auch und
was ja was ja auch interessant sind das
ja gerade sie die hier jede woche aus
teilen bis zum gipfel
und wenn dann die kritik zurück kommt
sie wie die mimosen rumheulen sie
ungerecht das denn alles ist ja sie bei
uns auch im beruf ich kenne das doch
auch in den rumpf wollen so müsste man
sich ja ich sage ich will es das ja nur
einmal aufrufen ich bin im einstecken
als linker sehr ausgebildet und ich will
ihnen sagen dass ausgerechnet sie die
bei überschreitungen dieser zum
geschäftsmodell gemacht haben ansonsten
kämen sie ja nicht vor weil sie
inhaltlich nicht vorzuweisen haben sie
berufen sich immer auf die
pressefreiheit die sie heute grundlegend
infrage stellt ist ein gewisser
widerspruch und zum schluss zum schluss
es ist auch wirklich schon relativ wie
zart dass ausgerechnet sie die
ununterbrochen vor einer herbei
halluzinierte islamisierung deutschlands
reden
ausgerechnet mit dem islamisten erdogan
gegen den journalisten stellt und die
pressefreiheit vorgehen das muss nun
doch mal auffallend ich bin so
freundlich sie aus diesem widerspruch
aufmerksam zu machen
zum schluss zum schluss eine kleine
denksportaufgabe es gibt ja gerade in
deutschland mit den vielen
parteistatuten und vereinen so was wie
ehrenmitgliedschaften mein tipp wäre ich
hätte einen heißen kandidaten für eine
ehrenmitgliedschaft bei ihm den
türkischen präsidenten erdogan
ihr antrag wird selbstverständlich volle
kanne abgelegt
meine damen und herren das noch mal klar
zu sagen die äußerung von denise
witschel im einzelnen sind sicherlich
diskussionswürdig da sie aber ganz klar
als satire gekennzeichnet waren
muss man sie auch in diesem kontext
verstehen satire ist eine
journalistische spielart und dies durch
das deutsche grundgesetz geschützt
nichts erinnert man muss sich
vergegenwärtigen worüber wir heute
tatsächlich hier reden wir reden über
die arbeit und den artikel eines
deutschen journalisten
so etwas kennen wir eigentlich sonst nur
aus autoritären ländern
der deutsche bundestag hingegen benotet
nicht die arbeit von journalisten und
journalistinnen bei unserer bundestag
deutschland gibt es keine oberste
zensurbehörde parlament es gibt es in
den ländern die sie bewundert
deutschland gehört nicht dazu
daraus in deutschlands in unserem land
im bundestag deutschland gibt es keine
gleichschaltung von der sie nachts
träumen bei uns gibt dass pressefreiheit
ein wort das in ihren wortschatz ganz
offensichtlich nicht vorhanden bis sehr
geehrte damen und herren und diese
pressefreiheit und diese pressefreiheit
die werden wir ihnen gegenüber genau so
verteidigen wie ihren genossen gegenüber
die in der türkei den sl ein jahr seines
lebens geklaut haben wir sind froh wir
sind froh dass die sozial frei ist wie
will das mal sagen dass wir auch kein
missverständnis entsteht genauso froh
wären wir beinahe gustav müller oder
sonstwie heißen würde weil jeder bürger
dieses landes verdient hat dass dieses
land sich für ihn einsetzt bisher wohl
eine selbstverständlichkeit jeder weiß
dass außer ihnen
und wir alle der demokratische teil
dieses hauses setzt sich auch dafür ein
dass die anderen journalisten die
ebenfalls in haft sind aber keinen
deutschen pass haben es genauso verdient
haben freigelassen werden weil
journalismus ist kein verbrechen sehr
geehrte damen und herren aber aber zur
wahrheit gehört leider auch das land hat
sich in dem ein jahr in dem der csa im
gefängnis war dramatisch verändert und
davon zeugt diese debatte in
mittlerweile sitzen abgeordneten diese
maus die kann ich nicht anders
bezeichnen als rassisten wer sich so
gebiert ist ein rassist sehr geehrte
damen und herren und diese damen und
herren hier und diese damen und herren
hier und diese damen und herren hier ich
habe das mikrofon
dann können sie es mir nicht abstellen
ich weiß von dem regime in dem sie
träumen kann das mikrofon abgestellt
aber das kann man hier gott so lange
nicht und sie werden es nicht schaffen
glauben sie es mir
sie wollen bestimmen sie wollen
bestimmen wer deutsches wer nicht
das heißt wie kann jemand der
deutschland der unsere gemeinsame heimat
so verachtet wie sie es tun darüber
bestimmen wer deutsch ist und wer nicht
welches die sage im 1 wenn sie wenn sie
darüber bestehen hören
das wäre ungefähr so wie wenn rassisten
des ausstiegs telefon für neonazis geben
würde das wäre ungefähr so wenn sie
darüber bestimmen würden mehr deutsche
ist und wer nicht deutsch ist übrigens
wenn sie die nummer des ausstiegs
telefons der neonazis brauche nicht
absehen ich kann sie ihn gern zur
verfügung stellen kollege ekström
eigentlich geschah die tat inzwischen
frage sie alle wie sie da sitzen von der
afg wenn sie ehrlich sind dann würde sie
zugeben dass sie dieses land verachten
sie verachten alles sie verachten alles
wofür dieses land in der ganzen welt
geachtet werden respektiert wird dazu
gehört beispielsweise unsere
erinnerungskultur auf die stolz bereits
bürger dieses landes
dazu gehört die vielfalt in diesem land
auf wie ich genauso stolz bin dazu
während bayern schwaben und dazu gehören
aber auch menschen deren vorfahren aus
russland kommen und dazu gehören
menschen deren vorfahren aus anatolien
kommt und jetzt genauso stolz darauf
sind bürger dieses landes zu sein und
dazu gehört und dazu gehört das muss ich
schon mal sagen der für die jahre als
fußball fan persönlich angesprochen dazu
gehört unsere großartige
nationalmannschaft wenn sie ehrlich sind
drücken sie noch den russen die daumen
und nicht unsere deutschen
nationalmannschaft gehen sie es doch zu
dieses hohe haus dieses hohe haus
verachten sie genauso wie sie die werte
der aufklärung verachten sie sind aus
demselben holz geschnitzt wie diejenigen
die den easyjet verhaften lassen haben
sie sind aus demselben faulen haus
geschnitzt wie erdogan
der dänische shell ein jahr seines
lebens verhaftet hat ich sag's mal in
einem satz die akp in deutschland die
hat ein ableger des afg und sie sitzt
hier sehr geehrte damen und herren dass
sie mich zum schluss sagen dass sie mich
zum schluss sagen sie haben vor kurzem
in politischen aschermittwoch mich hat
es eher eine rede im sportpalast sehr
geehrte damen und herren und ich will
ihn zu rufen unser deutschland dieses
deutschland ich stärker als sie es
jemals sein wird oder ob hier toben da
macht er toll gemacht wollte mich am
aschermittwoch abschieben das geht
leicht lassen sich das vorstellen am
kommenden samstag bin ich wieder in
meine heimat ich flieg nach stuttgarter
nämlich die s-bahn und ich lande am
endbahnhof bad urach da ist meine
schwäbische heimat und die lasse ich mir
von ihnen nicht kaputt machen
zu mir hat sich da ziemlich in rage
geredet also eins kann man den 90 im
bundestag wirklich nicht nachsagen der
legislaturperiode genau gesagt das ist
ja langweilig würde auch um die suche
zeit übrigens sehr gut gefülltes haus
denn die landschaft der ard wird hier
gleich auch namentlich aufgerufen
abgestimmt und deswegen sind eben auch
um diese zeit so viele parlamentarier
hier im haus erst einmal der hinweis
geschäftszeit das kann durchaus
passieren
ganz egal wer aus dem präsidium des
deutschen bundestages hier vorn gerade
dienst hat dass es auch entscheidungen
gibt oder handlungen von amtierenden
präsidentinnen und präsidenten die ein
fehler enthalten oder aber die
nachträglich in irgendeiner weise zu
lösen dazu wir regeln und das hat einen
guten grund jedenfalls tragen wir das
hier nicht in im plenum des bundestages
miteinander aus sondern der ort für
diese ganze geschichte ist der
ältestenrat und wenn einzelne
abgeordnete und zwar jetzt mal
wechselseitig ich nehme hier auf
forderungen sehr wohl zur kenntnis trotz
des hohen lärmpegels unzufrieden sind
mit meiner sitzungsleitung dann werden
wir das entweder nächsten donnerstag 14
uhr in der nächsten regulären sitzung
des ältestenrates behandeln und
ansonsten wissen denke ich die
geschäftsführerin und geschäftsführer
wie wir auch wenn es notwendig werden
sollte zu einer sondersitzung des
ältestenrates kommen um diese dinge zu
regeln
im übrigen und das will ich dann auch
gleich sagen
baumann ich konnte weder alle
zwischenrufe wieder aus allen fraktionen
hier vorne verstehen aufgrund des sehr
hohen lärmpegels noch jetzt bin ich dran
und nur ich
noch war es mir möglich in dieser
hitzigen debatte alle äußerungen die
hier vorn das gilt nicht nur für den
letzten beitrag getroffen wurden in
ihrer tragweite und wirkung hier bis
zuletzt zu überschauen aber auch dafür
haben wir regeln sollte es in dieser
debatte dinge gegeben haben die die
regeln überschritten haben haben wir den
ort über den ich gerade sprach um
gegebenenfalls auch nachträglich in
irgendeiner weise etwas zusammen zu
nieren- oder einzugreifen ich habe im
moment keine veranlassung
hiervon hier vorn jetzt die debatte
weiter aufzuhalten sondern ich nehme
sowohl die dinge die hier angemeldet
wurden zur kenntnis wir werden sie einer
entsprechenden beratung zu führen und
ich bitte jetzt in geschäftsleitenden
hinweis in der weiteren debatte zu
verfolgen
und dazu hat jetzt die abgeordnete
elisabeth motschmann führen die cdu csu
fraktion ist offensichtlich hat sich der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der fdp
über äußerungen und auch über die
sitzungsleitung beschwert aber peter
brauch und der linken die die
sitzungsleitung hat hat ja hier klare
worte gefunden und vielleicht war es
auch ganz gut hier eine kleine
unterbrechung herbeizuführen
ende märz hatte sich in der tat ziemlich
in rage geredet vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr sachlichkeit in der debatte wäre
dann auch ganz gut fürs hohe haus jetzt
also elisabeth motschmann
der unionsfraktion
im letzten jahr sagte erdogan noch er
wird niemals frei gelassen er ist frei
angela merkel hat sich bemüht
der außenminister hat sich bemüht das
ist ihr job sie hatten erfolg dafür
sagen wir danke und sogar ohne
verabredung gegenleistung oder deals das
ist wichtig viele weitere deutsche und
türkische journalisten sind nach wie vor
in haft sechs türkische journalisten
lebensland das ist schlimm
natürlich müssen wir uns am um jeden
einzelnen kümmern und versuchen für die
freiheit zu kämpfen
die afc betont in ihrem antrag dass
dennis mitchell eine vorzugsbehandlung
bekommen hätte viermal traf das auf sie
unterstellen dass weniger prominente und
öffentliche fälle weniger intensiv
behandelt werden falsch ich habe die
familie eines inhaftierten persönlich
betreut
den kannte keiner ein bilder der an
einen friedensmarsch teilgenommen hat er
ist frei
dank der bemühungen der bundesregierung
also ihre ihre aussage stimmt nicht
alles beide kommentiert die freilassung
von pz news
es wurde hier schon angesprochen ich
zitiere ein unser land regelrecht hassen
der journalist der nicht nur einmal die
grenzen des guten geschmacks release
sollte eigentlich
keine deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
besitzen zitat ende eine unglaubliche
äußerung meine damen und herren
meinungsfreiheit und pressefreiheit sind
nicht verhandelbar in unserem land 7
sie sind vom grundgesetz geschützt und
das sollte eigentlich alles beide wissen
auch mir gefallen manche positionen von
denis hughes überhaupt nicht dass dazu
gehört dass er 2011 2012 in einer touch
kolumne über den geburten sport und
geschrieben hat aber das kann doch
niemals ein grund sein seine deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft in frage zu stellen
meine damen und herren
welch ein unsinn es wäre sinnvoller
übrigens das sage ich der afd
wenn sie sich um die
menschenverachtenden aussagen ihrer
eigenen parteifreunde kümmern würden
bevor sie mit dem finger auf andere
zeigen
der aschermittwoch ist noch nicht so
lange her und was hat koppenburg gesagt
kümmel kümmel händlern und kümmel
treibern die sich da dahin skiern sollen
wo sie hingehören weit weit hinter den
bosporus zu den lehmhütten und viel
weibern zitat ende
das ist widerlich meine damen und herren
und im übrigen cabrio sie hatten ja von
morast gesprochen das ist das was wir da
erleben in ihren reihen und herr bauland
[Applaus]
es hat mich schon gewundert dass sie
dazu sagen es gebe keinen bedarf eine
innerparteiliche debatte anzustrengen
und dann kommt der satz das bewegt mich
nicht dass es eine ethische
bankrotterklärung ergaunern
wenn sie das nicht mehr bewegt dann
haben sie ihren beruf verfehlt nicht
berichtigt kollegen an
sie haben die chance wenn sie eine
fragen oder bemerkungen zu lassen noch
die ablaufende reden verletzte frau
kollegin sie haben gerade wie ich meine
durchaus nicht auf das wirkliche thema
reagiert in ihrer rede und sie haben
gerade auch von einer bankrotterklärung
gesprochen und ich frage sie deshalb in
diesem zusammenhang wenn dieses hohe
haus nicht bereit ist eine solche
äußerungen wie die von herrn götschel zu
verurteilen dann frage ich sie ob es
nicht auch nach ihrer meinung eine
bankrotterklärung dieses hohen hauses
ist ob wir uns nicht alle gemein machen
mit denen die auf demonstration süden
lauthals rufen deutschland verrecke das
ist auch hier die frage
ich war ich weiß nicht herr kollege
ob sie probleme mit den leuten haben ich
habe doch eben gesagt dass mir auch
nicht alles gefällt was dennis gehl
gesagt und geschrieben hat und ich habe
genau so gesagt dass es eine ethische
bankrotterklärung ist wenn man die
eigenen miesen äußerungen in der afc
nicht entsprechend auch zurückweist
und schließlich und endlich ich komme zu
meiner rede zurück
und wenn die afg dann zu allem überfluss
in ihrem wahlprogramm dass ich sehr
genau studiert habe meinen dass ihre
grundsätze auf den werten des
christentums fußen dann kann ich ihnen
nur bescheinigen dass angesichts solcher
äußerungen und solcher dümmlichen
anträge ihre werte nichts aber auch gar
nichts mit dem christentum zu tun haben
[Applaus]
uns jetzt auf die zeit ja ich bin ich
bin am ende nicht am ende sondern ich
komme zum ende
freuen sie sich zu früh
ich will nur noch am ende bischöfin ilse
junkermann zitieren die zu ihrer zu
gucken wo ich gesagt hat die rede hat
erneut den unverblümten hast gezeigt mit
dem die afg menschen diffamiert und sie
fährt fort unsere gesellschaft braucht
verantwortliche mit umsicht und
weitblick und keine vor hass und
menschenverachtend achtung blinden
abgeordneten
danke frau bischöfin dieser weitblick
und diese um sich fehlt der afd
daran sollten sie arbeiten vielen dank
meinungsfreiheit und pressefreiheit sind
nicht verhandelbar in diesem land hat
elisabeth motschmann abgeordnete gegeben
button beiträge hier hören
wenigen die zur bevorstehenden
abstimmung schon herbei geeilt sind auch
platz zu nehmen
peter brauerei weist darauf hin dass
noch zwei redner hier ihre redezeit vor
sich haben und dass er in knapp neun
minuten hier die abstimmung erst beginnt
viele abgeordnete haben sich hier schon
an der seite versammelt und unterhalten
sich zu laut das moniert sie völlig zu
recht denn die beiden letzten redner
sollen natürlich hier auch noch die
chance haben ihre rede ungestört halten
zu können
und jetzt weiß sie auch noch abgeordnete
zurecht ich weiß jetzt nicht auf wen das
gemünzt war die mitglieder der
bundesregierung sind
der bundesinnenminister sitzt hier ganz
hinten sehe ich gerade hatte sich
unterhalten hat sich aber in die reihen
der abgeordneten gesetz da wird er wohl
auch bald platz nehmen denn
offensichtlich wird ja in einem neuen
kabinett keine neue position mehr
bekleiden können thomas de maizière
also hat darauf verzichtet nach vorne zu
gehen hat sich hinten gleich eingesetzt
und petra pau ist doch gestrengen hier
mit einigen hier von meiner
kommentatoren kabine da knubbeln sich
noch ein paar unionsabgeordnete drüben
sehe ich noch ganz wenige grüne auf der
anderen seite und die setzen sie jetzt
auch alle hin
naja dann warten wir halt alle noch ein
bisschen bis peter paul auch zufrieden
ist es geht ja darum dass die letzten
beiden redner ja auch tatsächlich mit
der gebotenen notwendige aufmerksamkeit
ihrer rede hier absolvieren können
so sehr schön da sehen wir noch einige
abgeordnete die allerdings jetzt hier
glaube ich gerade erst rein gekommen
waren und die sich sitzen es kommen wir
mal wieder rein das ist ja normal und
martin rabanus wird jetzt aufgerufen von
der spd der vorletzte redner in der
debatte
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren natürlich ist
schon deutlich geworden in der debatte
dass es hier mitnichten auch bei dem
antrag mitnichten um den fall dennis
jale geht sondern es geht um nach
haltung die in düsterer art und weise
uns hier deutlich geworden ist von dem
was die kolleginnen und kollegen der afd
zur pressefreiheit und derlei mehr
denken
es gibt aber auch den anlass und das ist
das schöne an der debatte festzustellen
dass eine übergroße mehrheit dieses
parlament dass es anders sieht das ist
sozusagen die positive botschaft die mit
der debatte auch verbunden ist und es
ist dann hat man ein bisschen gefühl
dafür was die redner so sagen und das
ist auch gut so dann wenn wir über
faltungen reden und wenn wir über die
frage am ende des tages reden wie wir
uns unser deutschland vorstellen
denn darum geht es dann will ich sagen
ich stelle mir in deutschland vor
wie es eben im jahre 2018 ist nichts mit
80er jahren des letzten jahrhunderts
nicht in den 50er und schon gar nicht in
den 30er oder 40er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts sondern eben ein heutiges
deutschland und ich möchte in einem
deutschland leben in dem unsere jungs in
der fußballmannschaft cem özdemir hat
das angedeutet im ganz
selbstverständlich müller für mich oder
dachser heißen aber genauso
selbstverständlich eben özil khedira
oder boateng und wenn sie bei mir in der
nachbarschaft boden
fällt für das auch ausgesprochen und ich
möchte in einem land leben in dem es
eben tolerant und weltoffen zugeht
ja und genau deswegen soll das auch so
bleiben und genau deswegen müssen wir
hier auch ziemlich deutlich werden
denn wir müssen unsere politische arbeit
doch darauf richten teilhabe von
menschen zu ermöglichen menschen beim
arbeitsmarkt teilhaben zu lassen an
bildung zugang zu sozialen
sicherungssystemen kunst und kultur um
nur ein paar stichworte zu nennen
ich möchte in einem deutschland leben in
der unterschiedliche lebenskonzepte
familien und beziehungs konzepte möglich
sind doch um all diese fragen geht es
wie sieht dieses deutschland eigentlich
aus ich möchte da im land leben in dem
meinungsfreiheit herrscht in dem
freiheit von kunst und kultur geachtet
und geschützt wird in dem pressefreiheit
respektiert und geschützt wird und ich
möchte an land leben in dem journalisten
satiriker kritiker querdenker
kabarettisten ihre arbeit frei machen
können frei machen können wo sie zu
schützen können
wo sie provozieren können und zwar egal
ob das jetzt dieter nuhr aus wesel oder
deniz yücel aus flörsheim ist das
nämlich ein hessischer group sehr
geehrte damen und herren von der ard wir
wussten dass übrigens auch nicht alles
gefallen was diese kabarettisten sagen
darum geht es überhaupt nicht
ich muss mir das auch nicht zu eigen
machen ich muss da nicht bei allem jubel
und auch ist klar in unserem land wer in
der ausübung seiner eigenen rechte
seiner freiheitsrechte seiner
künstlerischen freiheit andere rechte
verletzt
er muss sich dafür auch verantworten
auch das ist klar aber das ist eine
frage die im rechtsstaatlichen system
rechtsstaatliche stellen zu klären haben
und nicht politische reglementierung
hervorrufen darf ich jedenfalls will in
deutschland leben
das nie wieder auch nur in den verdacht
kommt das politische zensur zulässig
sein
warum das klar zu machen es geht ihm
nicht um den fall
es geht ihnen um ihre haltung eine die
meinungs- kunst und pressefreiheit mehr
oder weniger subtil in frage stellt und
dazu kann ich ihnen abschließend zwei
sachen sagen das eine das ist
unanständig und erbärmlich das zweite es
wird auf unseren widerstand stoßen
vielen dank martin rabanus war das für
die spd und der letzte redner hier in
der debatte zum verhalten der
bundesregierung im fall dennis mitchell
ein antrag der afd
der letzte redner also kommt von der
union volker ullrich
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren freude und
erleichterung sind unsere gefühlslagen
wenn über die haftentlassung von dennis
kelly empfinden
aber wir tragen auch sorge in uns in
bezug auf all diejenigen journalisten
die noch in der türkei inhaftiert sind
und in jüngster zeit auch zu langen
freiheitsstrafen verurteilt worden
von dieser stelle erinnert die türkei
ist vertragspartner der europäischen
menschenrechtskonvention und als solche
sind presse und meinungsfreiheit
meinungsfreiheit wesentliche
bestandteile dieses vertragswerk auch
daran muss sich die türkei halten und
mehr über die bewertung der arbeit von
dennis wird stellt politiker der afg
sprechen dann kann man nicht daran
vorbei dass die fraktionsvorsitzende
alles gesagt hat michelle ist weder
journalist noch deutscher das ist
deswegen besonders niederträchtig und
empörend weil die staatsangehörigkeit
dazu führt dass jemand in die werte und
verantwortungsgemeinschaft unseres
landes eintritt wer allerdings jemandem
die staatsangehörigkeit abspricht wegen
seiner herkunft oder wegen seines
aussehens der muss wissen dass es sich
außerhalb des verfassungs bogens bewegt
die äußerungen von dennis mitchell über
viele jahre journalistische arbeit kenne
ich persönlich größtenteils nicht und
die äußerungen die sie in dem antrag
zusammengefasst haben sind teilweise aus
dem kontext gerissen
aber es kommt gar nicht darauf an ob
diese äußerungen mir persönlich gefallen
es wäre weder meine sprache noch mein
inhalt entscheidend ist was anderes es
geht um die frage welche reichweite hat
meinungsfreiheit in diesem land und
dieser gesellschaft ich bitte sie zur
kenntnis zu nehmen dass die
meinungsfreiheit schlicht wie
konstituierend für eine freiheitliche
demokratische gesellschaft ist und das
ohne meinungs- und pressefreiheit
demokratie nicht möglich ist
wenn sie also sagen dass der deutsche
bundestag die bundesregierung auffordern
solle eine einzelne meinungsäußerung zu
missbilligen
dann hat das noch eine ganz andere note
nämlich eine wo sie sich ebenfalls
außerhalb des verfassungs bogens bewegen
es ist nicht aufgabe staatlicher organe
meinungen zu kommentieren zu bewerten
oder gar zu tendieren pflegerisch
gestatten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
nein alles gesagt wer mehr als wer als
journalist oder als jemand der eine
meinung tätigt gegen die rechte andere
verstößt ja den der wird von den
gerichten wenn er die meinungsfreiheit
überschreitet auch entsprechend verfolgt
beleidigung und volksverhetzung sind in
diesem land zu recht strafbar
und das sollten auch einige von ihnen
bitte zur kenntnis nehmen aber es ist
nicht unser konzept eines freiheitlichen
staates dass wir vorschriften machen die
jemand zu denken und zu reden hat und
wer das möchte befindet sich in einem
anderen staat wieder in einem start ohne
meinungsfreiheit in einem start ohne
demokratie zu einem autoritären
gemeinwesen in einem gemeinwesen in die
freie rede in dem die das miteinander
und am ende des tages auch die
demokratie gefährdet sind deswegen sagen
ihnen ehrlich wehret den anfängen
ein solcher antrag ist
verfassungsfeindlich und das pixi zur
kenntnis wie man deswegen linien ab
volker ullrich war das für die union
es geht jetzt hier gleich in der
abstimmung namentlich aufgerufen
beziehungsweise namentlich durchgeführt
ballon um den antrag der afg in ihrem
antrag die afd
denis hughes einen ausgewiesenen
deutschland und deutschen hasser und
wirft ihrem volksverhetzende äußerungen
vor die stehe im missverhältnis fuhr zur
vorzugsbehandlung des journalisten durch
die bundesregierung
denn es wird der kollege war lange
mitglied der taz hat für die taz viele
kolumnen geschrieben die bereiche
überspitzt waren man nennt das im
journalistischen auch satire die waren
auch als solche klar zu erkennen da
waren so setzte drin wie der baldigen
abgang der deutschen aber ist völker
sterben von seiner schönsten seite er
hatte das vorher und hinterher noch
einmal ausgeführt in einer über
pointierten art und weise das nun
wirklich jeder leser merken konnte dass
das sich hier um satire handelt aber
dass sie die auf die anders und deswegen
will sie dass die bundesregierung unter
anderem diesen satz hier kritisiert die
meinungsfreiheit und die pressefreiheit
sind allerdings in diesem land nicht
verhandelbar sagte ehefrau almuth mann
und deswegen wird dieser antrag auch
keine mehrheit finden sie sehen jetzt
also dass die amtierende
tagungspräsidentin petra pau hier die
abgeordneten zur ohne ruft dann wird
gleich das namenskärtchen eingeschmissen